um but hopefully also we will hear from  salem later on um but just in case just  so we don't miss those interviews tanya  is making her way there okay okay he did  take the pawn that's just the pony  actually style he doesn't want to sit  and suffer so he's taking that pawn he's  allowed a check the white queen  recapturing another pawn with check  level number of pawns now and black's  pawn over there on a6 is about to drop  off  okay  the black king stepping forward and now  there's a threat in the position so if  you do go rook takes pawn or queen takes  porn then black can simplify things even  further by actually giving a check to  the white king on c8 square and they've  gone because the mu 40 has been made  [Laughter]  typical stuff they did it at the same  time as well  we have reached the time control the  players  are taking a little break from their  chairs